hi my name is namazo and this talk is
about incompressibility and next block
solar entropy this is a joint work with
the stuff Eichner and judge silvock
let me start with talking about pseudo
Randomness which is a computational
analog of Randomness and a basic concept
about in cryptography and complexity in
the context of cryptography we Define a
pseudo random message follows we say
that the distribution X over n Bits is
pseudorandom
if we cannot distinguish between x to
the universe uniform distribution
Overland beats or if x is
computationally close to the uniform
distribution
we Define computationally closeness as
follows we said that X is computation
across the y if for every efficient
algorithm a the probability that a
output 1 on a simple form X is almost
the same as the probability of a to
Output 1 and a sampling for y
and formally in order to talk about
efficient algorithms or polytimes
algorithms we need some parameters that
goes to infinity or to talk about and
symbols of distributions but for
Simplicity in this talk I'm going to
ignore it and talk about specific
distribution
the reason that pseudonymous is so
useful is that we can use it in order to
construct pseudo-random generators which
is our primitive in cryptography that
can be used in order to construct for
for example encryption schemes
pseudomon generator is just just an
efficient computable function G from lbs
to n Bits such that the output of G on
the uniform distribution of the lbs is
pseudonym
and in order to make this definition
useful we require that L is much shorter
than n
so
a question we can ask is how to
construct pseudom generators or in other
words how to construct pseudorant
distributions
to understand it we need to talk about
Randomness and how to construct
Randomness and for this we need to
understand entropy
entropy is a refinement of fundaments or
actually a measure of randomness
the entropy of a distribution X is
defined to be the expectation over the
distribution X of the log 1 over
probability to get a specific sample
from the distribution
we think about the log one of our
probability as the amount of supplies we
have in this specific sample or the
amount of information we have in this
sample and by taking expectation we get
the expected amount of supplies in the
distribution X or the expected amount of
information index
atop has a few nice properties one of
them is that the entropy of X is the
expected number of random bits that we
can extract from the distribution X so
for example if x is the uniform
distribution over n Bits you can extract
from it n Bits of Randomness and indeed
the entropy of the uniform distribution
is and
and for other example if x is with
probability are bottom will be
probability of the uniform distribution
of the line bits then the enthalpy of X
is n over two plus one and indeed we can
extract from X N over 2 plus 1 bits on
average because we can extract one bit
from the event that we got button and
with probability of we get additional
end reads
another property that atops is that the
entropy of X is the minimum description
length of X or the minimal compression
length of the distribution X
one property that makes entropy very
useful is the fact that we can convert
convert entropy to randomness
so if we have a declaration y with
entropy at least k then we can use an
efficient possible that we call X Factor
that takes a number of samples from Y
and for each sample it output K bits
such that if we get the extractor same
as the drawn from the distribution y
independently then the output of the
extractor distributed uniformly or close
to uniform
so the extractor extract from each
sample of Y roughly K bits of fundaments
and in the computational settings we
know we can convert pseudo Randomness we
can convert pseudoentropy into
pseudoadamus
pseudomentropy is a notion defined by
astradaminobi and we said that the
distribution X as pseudoenthropy K if
there exists a distribution y with a
real entropy at least scale such that X
is computationally close to one
in other words x and student of PK if it
is indistinguishable from some
distribution that really has entropy to
escape
we get pseudonymous this is because if
we apply the extractor on y we get
something which is
indeed close to Randomness and we cannot
distinguish between X and Y so we cannot
distinguish between the output of the
extractor on Y and the output of the
extractor on X so the output of the
extractor on X is sub 1.
and this is useful in order to construct
pseudo Randomness and indeed answering
polyester Levine will be showed how to
construct so the randomness using this
inertia
and uh so the entropy is a computational
analog of entropy in the same way that
pseudo Randomness is a computational
analog of fund of this
and the point here is that by defining
this computation and analogues of
entropy and Randomness we are able to
apply information theoretic tools in the
computational settings
so computational analytics of entropy
are very useful in order to construct
cryptographic Primitives but we can try
to come up with a alternative
computational analogs of entropy and in
fact alternative computational of
entropies used to construct more
efficient pseudom generals
and the general approach to come up with
computation and analog of entropy is the
first Identify some problems in the
distribution with in to PF
and then to come up with a computation
and analog of this property
for example your show in 92 you have
defined the next bit unpredictability
property
inserted the distribution X over M bits
is mixed with unpredictable if for every
efficient algorithm or predictor the
threads X bit by bit in an online
fashion
the predictor cannot predict the next
bit of x given the prefix so is
advantage in predicting the height bit
of x given the I minus 1 and prefix is
at most r
and without the Restriction of on the
efficiency of the predictor this is just
our information theoretic property that
random distribution had but by limiting
the predictor to be efficient we get a
computation and analog of this property
and in fact Yahoo shows that next return
predictability is equivalent to
pseudonymous
okay
so till now we we saw a number of
computational analogs of entropy we
defined pseudoentalpy we talked about
next week unpredictability and
additional computation and analog we
knew is next with pseudoentropy defined
by either line code and for them
is a quantitative refinement of
unpredictability
instead of asking that the predictor in
cannot predict entirely the next bit of
X we only ask that the next bit is
somewhat Auto predicted
and we quantify this RNs exactly and
next with simulatory can be converted to
so the randomness using computation and
extraction techniques and thus it is
useful in order to construct pseudo
Randomness also the random generators
and in fact the best construction of
prgs we know today use this notion
but at least both next with
unpredictability and next with
pseudoentropy capture the
unpredictability property of
distribution with eye entropy and we can
try to come up with uh Notions that
captures
other properties that end up here
in other contexts in cryptography like a
cryptographic ash functions and
commitments there are other motions of
entropy like inaccessible entropy but we
are not going to talk about them today
today I want to talk instead on a
compressibility
so a compression scheme for distribution
X is just a pair of algorithms encoder
and decoder such that for every X in the
support of the distribution if we encode
X and then decode we get back the same
Central X
and our goal is to minimize the expected
encoding length of x
now just notice that the encoding length
of every sample from X can be different
this is not a fixed then accordingly
and uh Shannon showed that for at least
for useful compression schemes like
Graphics free schemes it's also that the
minimal the best compression scheme from
X
the expected encoding length is at least
the entropy of x
and also we know that for the best
compression scheme the expected encoding
lights is at most the entropy of X plus
one
so there is a tight connection between
compressibility and The Entity
and then you'll come up with a very
natural computation and analog of
entropy which he called the effective
entropy of X which which is just the
minimal expected encoding length of X
when we only consider efficient encoding
and decoding are positive
and this definition is also called
incompressibility of Yao's pseudohertope
and we are going to refer it as
incompressibility
so let me Define it more formally we say
that our distribution X is 10
compressible if for every poly size
compression scheme encodone decoder the
expected and causing length of X is at
least k
and this is a non-uniform definition you
can come up with a uniformly variant of
this definition but this is the way Yao
Define it
and the connection or relations between
this definition and other computational
analog of enthalpy is not well
understood
there is a
stronger worst case notion of
incompressibility
showed that if we have a distribution
with this stronger notion then we can
extract from it K minus Omega flow K uh
pseudo randomness
and this was used in order to construct
prgs in the from alness in the
complexity context
but again this is only from the stronger
motion
so just as a quick recap
we've seen clearly computational analogs
of entropy we talked about pseudonym we
said that the distribution X and student
opk if it's indistinguishable from some
distribution y that really is entropy at
least okay
we talked about next with pseudom
entropy without a definition we said
that this is a refinement of next bit
unpredictability
and we defined in compressibility we
said that the distribution X is 10
compressible if we cannot compress it
efficiently to less than cables
and now the main question of this work
is what is the relation between and
compressibility to other computational
analogs of entropy
and we also ask if a non-trivial
incompressibility imply cryptography
by non-trivial I mean a distribution
that cannot be compressed efficiently to
its entropy or in other words a
distribution that is incompressibility
strictly larger than its relentable
and when we ask it's non-trivial in
compatibility implies cryptography we
ask if we can use such a distribution
with non-rivering compressibility in
order to construct for example
pseudo-random generators or encryption
schemes
so let's see our results
but first let me Define formally next
bit sooner
so we said that the solution X as next
leads to the enthalpy K if there exists
other discrimination why
jointly distributed with x
such that for every eye the first I bit
of X are in indistinguishable from the I
minus one first bits of X and the height
width of I
and the sum of enthalpies of y i given
the I minus one prefix effect is at
least k
now if we require the the entropy of Phi
I given the prefix of X is 1 for every I
then this definition was the same as the
next bit unpredictability notion
but when we all only ask that the sum of
the enthalpies is at this guy we get
that the next bit of R of X is just
someone out to be predicted given the
prefix
okay
so our main theorem is that
incompressibility implies next bit
sooner okay
so we showed that uh distribution X
which is K incapacitor is a distribution
with at least K minus 2 next bit to the
entropy so in compressibility implied
next bit sooner entropy
and a corollary of this theorem is that
if
T copies of X are T times k
incompressible then acts as next bit so
the entropy at least K minus 2 over t so
if you cannot compress T copy of X
efficiently to T times K bits on
expectation that X is next with pseudo
entropy replica
so now how the words looks like after we
have this theorem so we also the entropy
in compressibility and next means to the
entropy we already knew the distribution
with K bits of pseudoentropy is a
distribution with K net bits of the
entropy and similarly we already knew
that the distribution with K so the
entropy is a distribution with K minus
Del K in compressibility
we also knew that there is a
distribution which came next with to the
entropy that doesn't have K to the power
of 0.01 to the entropy so next bit so
the enthalpy doesn't imply so the right
of it and similarly there is an overcame
with respect to there is a distribution
which can compressibility that doesn't
have K to the power of 0.01 so don't
entropy so also in compressibility is a
weaker notion than student entropy at
least with respect to someone
in our work we showed that a dissolution
which is claim compressible is a
distribution with K minus two next with
pseudo entropy so in compressibility
implies next bit to the entropy up to
this two-bit stop
in the other direction we know that next
bits of example entropy doesn't imply in
compressibility but we showed that in
compressibility actually implies
stronger notion than next bit sudo
entropy we called strong next bit
pseudoentropy and this notion does imply
incompressibility so a distribution with
case strong next bit student entropy is
a distribution which is K into possible
and a distribution which is can
compressible is a distribution with K
minus 2 strong next principle entropy so
these two Notions are equivalent up to
this topic
our second result is that
incompressibility implies cryptography
so when we say that incomplexibility
implies cryptography we actually
decided in compressibility implies One
Way function
One Way function is the minimal
assumption in cryptography in the sense
that almost all useful Primitives in
cryptography implies money function and
using one function we can construct many
useful derivatives such as pseudonym
generators and encryptions
a valid function is a function that is
easy to compute so we have an efficient
algorithm that given an input x to the
function and put f of x but it is out
doing that so there is no efficient
algorithm that given f of x output X
and in this work we are focusing on
Sample and distribution so uh
distribution X is sample that if there
is an efficient algorithm
that uh given the uniform distribution
given Randomness output samples from X
and the output of a is distributed
according to x so a distribution X is
sampling if it is an output of efficient
probabilistic algorithm
implies boundary function so every
sample the distribution with next bit
pseudometropy larger than its entropy
implies when a function and thus implies
cryptography
and using other theorem our first
theorem a dissolution with K and
compressive incompressibility implies
that distribution with next bit
pseudonym entropy at least K minus two
we showed that if one by one wave
function do not exist then every sample
of a distribution can be efficiently
compressed to its entropy plus two in
other words
if there is a distribution which is a
incompressible
with its entropy plus two then when we
function exists
and this is because if value function do
not exist by the result of ethernet
then the next bits of the entropy of
every distribution is equal to its
entropy and then our theorem says that
our distribution x with gain
compatibility is a distribution x with
entropy K minus
so we can compress X to its entropy
cluster
to conclude we we showed in this work
that incompressibility is equivalent to
strong next bit sodorant entropy
and for open questions we want to find
connection to other computational
analogs of entropy
we want to understand the uniform
variant of incompressibility
if we want to close this two bits gap
between incompressibility and strong
next visible
thanks